how do you say it's like an appropriate
amount of time before I think I'll get
seconds I would say like one to two
hours oh yeah I mean I went to a wedding
a few months ago and I didn't get food
forever was torture just to be courteous
or no I just didn't want to draw too
much attention to myself I technically
wasn't invited to that wedding well I'm
hungry and you know what Alex invited me
to have some of his birthday pizza so
I'm a half son all right yeah hey Alex I
don't know one time I went to this
birthday party and I didn't get my hands
on a piece of cake and tell pretty much
everyone had left and it was off of you
know leftover plates okay how many
people here even got pizza one two three
there's only six slices ah that's not
enough Itza just go for it Steve it and
you're obviously hungry yeah you know
what you're right I just didn't have to
wait to get second I'm gonna get
something hmm worth it hey yo hey do you
guys know who ate all the pizza mm-hmm
need a few other people finished it
thanks Alex dude why are you thanking
him it's uh it's his birthday pizza dude
his birthday was three months ago that
was my pizza Alex what the heck let me
get you another pizza said ok sure ok ok
right ok so I'm grading our bar mitts
for this weekend you want to come yeah